one thing that
i think is good good to think about if
you push somebody if you if you're
giving someone something to do kind of
making almost making it up not quite but
like hey we're going to run this battle
drill again hey we're going to do
another briefing hey we're going to
review this hey we're going to maintain
our weapons again
if you're doing that kind of stuff
you should you should give them time for
hey
right now we got an hour relax
you should give them a specific amount
of time
to stand down to relax to take a knee
whatever
i think that is important too if you're
trying to keep them busy all the time
that's not smart
you need to find a moment to go okay hey
we got a half an hour everybody take
your take your rock off relax
yeah see here it says keep your marines
occupied by delivering intelligence
briefs reviewing the rules of engagement
rehearsing immediate action drills
during the lulls and pace of operations
by doing so so you prevent disciplinary
problems by turning your squads thoughts
away from them
themselves to the work at hand again
good yes i like it i agree with it
however comma
you've got to give people a little bit
of downtime
is that kind of parallel whatever to uh
the idea of you know okay so you go to
the gym we'll say right so let's say you
want to go to the gym after work
not before work right after work
so if you let's say as a routine you go
from work you get off work and then you
go
straight to the gym that's better
than going home first
decompressing a little bit then going to
the gym right you know
i don't know if what you're talking
about is the same thing but it's 100
true i think so though because they're
you know when you get like down time or
whatever like too much downtime
essentially right like where it's not
like you have to rest and recover from
work to go to the gym unless you do and
that's a whole different thing yeah i'm
talking about the idea that you come
home from your office you know and
you're physically not exhausted maybe
mentally or but whatever you go straight
to the gym because you don't give your
your mind
just like i said a chance to think about
like yourself your own like how am i
feeling that man the mood and it's like
it kind of creeps up on you you know
when you have that downtime but if you
go straight to the gym you're like hey
we're still we're still moving you know
yeah you don't get a chance to that's
true that is that is accurate
and then
if you take that to the extreme where
you also knew not getting any rest at
all you don't have any downtime then you
gotta watch out for that yeah that's
almost like the idea that let's say your
your job is like super physically
demanding like you're what would you
would you say a drywall hanger or
something drywall just getting after it
yeah well that's one that you said you
did and it was kind of hard either way
let's say you did you know 11 12 hours
let's say roofer roofer yeah in the hot
sun even
boom okay go home take a little snoozer
even
then hit the gym you can be kind of like
refreshed a little bit i bet you'd be
better off just going straight there
though
i think so something i think there's
plenty of people here at our gym where
they're coming off of a long day of work
and construction and then it's like
right onto the mats you know
i think that's a better move bro i would
for me it's a better move mentally it's
a better move i think yeah physically no
you go
recover a little bit that's what i think
you're driving here you know you got
like a half an hour or whatever that's
what i'm saying mentally but because
when you're driving here you're thinking
about training
more than you're thinking about relaxing
i'll tell you that you go home
have a snack turn on the tv just for a
little bit you're letting the window
close that was one of the better
conversations we once had was you're
letting that window close yeah it's like
oh it's getting a little bit smaller a
little bit smaller oh can't make it oh
you know i got a little too busy
sometimes my wife will wake up early
hell yeah
and
like
there's that you know whatever that uh
gravity
of you know she's oh you know talking to
me and stuff all right yes yeah yeah oh
yeah
but we have workouts to do
you know
yes and that's like i'll come back down
to the house to like grab some more
water or something
because i'm in my garage you know
and then i go back down to like grab
some water
and she's awake
and she's having a cup of tea because
she's from england oh yeah and she's
like oh morning and i'm like and there's
that gravity you know
you kind of wish she honestly no offense
to my wife i kind of wish she wasn't
awake because i kind of want to like
hang out with her a bit you know yes i
have to not oh yeah that's real that's
real even with us
when we show up here whatever we want to
talk about some stuff you know do this
do that yeah the workout thing
especially with your wife because even
if you don't want to talk to your wife
i'm not saying that's my case
maybe even either way even if you don't
want to talk hypothetically
hypothetically you can't just disrespect
her and be like yeah cool story i'm busy
she knows what you're doing you're
working out take a minute talk to me i'm
your wife you know for better or worse
all this stuff and you're over here just
dissing me for like some
curls or whatever you're doing in there
you see what i'm saying and that's what
it really does feel like when you're
doing it
so yeah i can jam you on
i hope my wife sleeps i like when she's
i like it when she sleeps a little later
you know get gets her rest yeah get some
rest go dig it get some rest